what would you pack for lunch if you had
a
typical nine-to-five job yeah a
chicken steak beef jerky nuts i don't
know a salad
not no big shocker there yeah right just
don't eat the donuts in the office
next question no tuna sandwich no
tuna sandwich whole wheat bread tomato
lettuce sprouts that's your go-to no
that's what my mom would probably pack
for
me if she was packing my lunch
but people weren't asking what your mom
would back for you for lunch when you
were young
that wasn't a question i don't know but
it kind of what my mom would have had
for me when i was young
bb and jay all right cool there it is
that's good
bag of potato chips yeah well
that was pb and j good but but potato
chips are not good
i just made it it's the same it tastes
good actually but peanut butter is good
and of course what i would do is take
the potatoes and put them on the
uh all good
but yeah so there you go you guys know
what to eat come on
but here i i'm sure they're asking
because that is kind of a thing like you
have a nine-to-five job right especially
if kind of the culture is like okay i go
to work
and then boom we go we'll go to lunch me
and my boys from work
we got lunch maybe a bar maybe you know
kind of thing
but they want to break the cycle so it's
like you know it's not it's kind of
commonality
okay break the cycle bring your own
lunch yeah we'll definitely bring you a
lunch
not only will you eat better but you
also won't spend
19 for lunch yeah you'll spend you'll
spend like six dollars for lunch and
it'll be better for you so that's just
yeah yeah okay so maybe i should have
made that more clear don't go out to the
little
corner store and or whatever the corner
restaurant and spend 28 dollars for
crappy food that's gonna make you fat
and lazy
yeah just pack your own food that cost
six dollars that's going to make you
lean strong and smarter
yeah but and then therein comes this
question i think i don't know but i
think so
because let's say you've never done that
before
yeah sounds crazy but here's the thing
there we go how's this so
so greg train right he always eats up
and i don't think he ever like cooks at
home or whatever right
and me i'm kind of well i'd kind of do
both whatever but i could get home i go
like i have my go-to little things
right at home so we're talking and i was
explaining to him
oh yeah oh yeah i'll just do this when
i'm on the program i'll do this i'll
make this and he's like dang you
you actually do that i don't like cook
and make stuff at home he's all
surprised
yeah like he was like this foreign thing
for real okay i'll give you a go-to
right now
if you want to talk go twos you said
tuna i have
a tin chicken like i don't even know
what my wife calls it tin chicken
it comes yeah because i don't really
like fish
sure and so i have chicken in a can open
it up
put some mayonnaise in there you're
you're good yeah food yeah yeah do that
too
and you can get big big cans of chicken
yeah go to costco
yeah that's a good total go-to yeah yeah
that's a good one a lot of sodium a lot
of times in those ones
you know if you care about those kinds
of things but yeah there's a lot of
chicken in there too
you know what you can do with that too
if you have just a little bit more time
the chicken the one in the can sweet is
good because it's so fast
but if you um you can like
kind of halfway boil some chicken chop
it up
saute it with some stuff right and then
chop it up even more boom add the
mayonnaise it's kind of the same deal
and you can do it that way you don't
need like the canned chicken some people
do not prefer canned chicken though
that's cool that's the thing they can do
other things
yeah yeah then that's the other thing
i'm talking about anyway
so what you know how did your mom make
chicken yeah i you know
no this kid is like that one
you know how greg it was foreign to greg
to actually cook at home
it's foreign for people to actually make
a lunch so they're like man where do i
start with this thing
what do i do and then usually in fact
from what i understand anyway
usually it's kind of like oh all all
kind of sort of buy a lunch while i'm
not at work
you know maybe go to buy one of these
boxed lunches or something and then
bring it in
because it meant the thing it's
defeating the purple yeah it's a thing
but it's defeating the purpose
you make the lunch like a sandwich or
something like that yeah i'm telling you
cool it works that's the direction you
want to go that's my opinion